**Susan Daniels**: Welcome back all this is day two in the morning, part two of three of our five day boot camp so we've put into place our plan we've collected all of our requirements, and in that collection of requirements we realized that we need resources that are definitely outside of the.
**Susan Daniels**: The what's available in the organization right we just don't have the talent, or we don't have the tools we don't have certain capabilities and for this project to be successful and implemented solution on day three my apologies, this is day three.
**Susan Daniels**: appreciate that one frank so.
**Susan Daniels**: We, we are now at the point that we realize i'm going to have to go out of house to get this stuff right so we've got to enter into the realm of procurement.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, as a project manager, are we expected to be subject matter experts in procurement no, but we do need to know some basic concepts.
**Susan Daniels**: And what's covered in the next slides that we're going to go over is really table stakes, if it is minimum information that you need to be aware of.
**Susan Daniels**: It is been part of project management, since the beginning, it is something that you as a project manager need to be able to either work with the procurement department.
**Susan Daniels**: and follow the conversation at the table or act as i'm sort of the organization's advocate for your project in the procurement process Okay, yes, the arm the recording has started i'm saving it to cloud yes um.
**Susan Daniels**: So let's take a look at what kind of tools and what kind of deliverables that we're going to produce as part of our procurement management.
**Susan Daniels**: So these are some vocabulary words if you're not really familiar with you're going to need to.
**Susan Daniels**: kind of study, particularly statement of work okay statements of work are written by the buyer, but it is the seller, who uses it as almost their charter what they're being asked to do.
**Susan Daniels**: But we'll cover more i'm bear with me I just had a coughing fit during the break so if i'm a little raspy i'm just trying to catch my breath here.
**Susan Daniels**: Will I spend more time on change management later no i'm not anticipating doing that.
**Susan Daniels**: i'll be talking more about governance later and his role and maybe how to build your governance board so that component of it, yes i'll be going over a little later this morning.
**Susan Daniels**: So this particular slide is about the components of a procurement strategy so there's various aspects, if you will, of procurement.
**Susan Daniels**: And one of the things that we need to understand is where, in the development are we have our of our product, do we need to bring the vendor in.
**Susan Daniels**: And also, we need to consider have we written our statement of work so that it covers the different phases of delivery.
**Susan Daniels**: will cover some contract types and then we'll talk about the different phases of procurement, you know that the planning of it, the Managing of it, the monitoring and controlling other.
**Susan Daniels**: This slide helps you understand um Where are you bringing the vendor in in the development of your product all right.
**Susan Daniels**: Are you are you bringing them in in the planning and analysis they bringing them in helping you develop the detailed design um do you just need them to help you implement it and stop okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So these are where you may be in your process of your project you're bringing a vendor in.
**Susan Daniels**: But please also understand when you're writing a statement of work to bring a vendor in you need to think about your statement of work following this as well.
**Susan Daniels**: Have you looked at each aspect of how you're going to get your delivery.
**Susan Daniels**: You know, have they taken into consideration, how are they engaging with you on the design, how are they articulating their process for implementation.
**Susan Daniels**: What is their plans for testing that you are getting what you need right is there training that's going to be involved.
**Susan Daniels**: In you being able to use what you purchase, so this is both way to look at it from inside your House right inside your organization.
**Susan Daniels**: Have I covered it from end to end and then from each one of your vendors that you bring in you look at this checklist as well.
**Susan Daniels**: How they addressed each component so, then the question becomes miss Daniels, how do you get tested on this okay.
**Susan Daniels**: This is a good way to approach this would be, can you put these in the right order the wonderful thing about the new p.
**Susan Daniels**: I P MP exam test format format is that they can do more than multiple choice now.
**Susan Daniels**: So they can ask you to put things in order right, so this question this this slide lends itself to a kind of a format that says here are the elements of delivery solution, please put them in the right order.
**Susan Daniels**: I will focus your attention on where the problem area may be oftentimes testing and training might actually in some organizations occur before implementation so.
**Susan Daniels**: In your notes, make sure you understand the delivery solution per pmi the met the phases that it goes through per pmi is in this order you implement it, then you test it then you train for it.
**Susan Daniels**: You may have your own logic, but that's not the way you're being tested, not on your own logic or world experience this one is this is the right order the way you see it on the slide.
**Susan Daniels**: So when we are involved in trying to develop our procurement strategy.
**Susan Daniels**: One of the first questions we have to ask ourselves are to meet these requirements that I have as part of my project scope Can I make it in house or do I have to go buy it.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, sometimes when you don't have it, you should not have a knee jerk reaction, you should not just leap to the.
**Susan Daniels**: conclusion that well if I don't have that I need to go buy it.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, not always there are some making by Decision criteria what's listed on this slide is only some of them, there are many things to take into consideration.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Sometimes, if the learning curve, is not that steep Okay, and not that expensive to try to train your talent, that you have in house to be able to do it.
**Susan Daniels**: Sometimes it's a better investment for the organization in the long term to train their staff to fill that gap, and then the agency or Organization has that talent now for future iterations.
**Susan Daniels**: So don't immediately think just because you don't have it, you need to go buy it but i've got a nice slide i'm available on.
**Susan Daniels**: Excuse me.
**Susan Daniels**: Give me a minute i'm where did I.
**Susan Daniels**: Let me go F 11.
**Susan Daniels**: And it is.
**Susan Daniels**: here.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm gonna take this and put it up here, no I had that open home phone at one moment i've got it got several things going at the same time, right now, i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: My Pacific oh there we go just took me a moment thanks for your patience guys alright so we've got to make it by analysis video, and I want to give credit where credit's due these excellent video so do by are created by Barbara walters.
**Susan Daniels**: When planning procurement for your project it's helpful to keep in mind that there is a flip in the relationship where the project manager and team become the buyer and your vendor is the seller.
**Susan Daniels**: You may be accustomed to being the vendor and performing work on behalf of your customer, but now you are the customer.
**Susan Daniels**: So in procurement the buyer is the project manager, the project team or the internal organization and the seller is the vendor or provider and is external to the project organization.
In our busy lives were often faced with the decision of whether to perform certain work ourselves.
Or if it makes more sense to hire another person or company to do the work for us, maybe you're deciding whether to cook dinner this evening or get takeout from a restaurant.
Or maybe the decision is regarding whether to do your own work in the yard or garden, or if you'll hire a landscaping company to perform the task.
This is called a maker by Decision and you've likely made this decision, many times before.
In project management, the maker by Decision falls in the procurement area, and there are a number of factors that you may consider when making this type of decision.
The availability of resources is one key factor, perhaps your maker by analysis was initiated because you're too busy to perform the work or you don't have the necessary TEAM members and skill sets.
The cost is another factor and we'll evaluate the cost in detail in an upcoming example other factors that will need to consider include risk competencies and ethics.
let's say that we need a skilled electrician to fix faulty wiring I wouldn't even consider doing that work myself.
It would be too risky to try this work, because I don't have the knowledge, I would probably do more harm than good.
Likewise, I may decide not to hire a company to move a delicate family heirloom that is irreplaceable that's something I would probably want to do myself.
When considering competencies, it should be a given that whoever is carrying out the work should have the ability to perform the tasks.
And with regard to ethics when choosing a vendor creating a level playing field for all prospective vendors and disclosing any personal relationships, would be an expectation.
So when we're performing a maker by analysis, we should assume that both parties have the equal ability to perform the work.
And that there are no ethical issues with the perspective vendor and that, ultimately, the decision will be based on pricing.
Also, when we say make or by make simply means that will perform the work ourselves in house, while by means that will obtain the services from a third party external to our organization.
It doesn't necessarily mean by it could also mean rent or lease in this exercise will analyze the recruitment of a position in our organization.
We can either use a staffing agency or directly hire the person into our organization if we decide to do this ourselves the cost is a $5,000 initial investment then $25 per day to maintain.
If we decide to go with a third party, the cost is $2,000 plus $100 per day so which decision is best that depends, how many days will we need this person for.
So the deciding factor is the number of days, this is the variable, we need to solve for.
In order to perform the maker by analysis will place the cost to buy on one side of the formula and the cost to make on the other.
will remove all dollar signs and solve for X, I understand that you may need a step by step walkthrough of this process or a little refresher and algebra.
So let's go through the steps of this maker by analysis together once you place the cost to buy and the cost to make on either side of the equation.
The next step is to solve for X, one of the Rules of algebra is whatever you do on one side of the equation, you must do the exact same thing, on the other side of the equation.
So we're going to get all of the x's on one side will subtract 25 X from the right side of the equation, to make it disappear from that side.
And that means we must also subtract 25 X from the left side of the equation this leaves us with 2000 plus 75 X equals 5000.
Now the next thing we can do is get all of the whole numbers isolated on one side of the equation, so will subtract 2000 from the left side of the equation, to make it disappear from that side.
This means we must also subtract 2000 from the right side of the equation, so this leaves us with 75 X equals 3000.
The last thing we need to do to isolate X is to divide both sides by 75 now we know that X equals 40 but what exactly does that mean.
When we calculated that X equals 40 we found the break even point for our maker by decision.
40 days is the point where the cost to make and the cost to buy are exactly the same before day 40 it's a better decision to buy or go with the third party vendor.
But, over time, that $100 fee per day for maintenance really starts to add up, and if we need this employee for more than 40 days we may want to consider hiring them directly.
**Susan Daniels**: So that was an excellent video by bb talking about the things you take into consideration when making them make or by decision and it also talks about how to calculate.
**Susan Daniels**: Like the break even point between making by will be asked to do a calculation there's a potential that you may so reviewing that video, which should be something you put in your notes, it is something you may potentially be asked to calculate um.
**Susan Daniels**: You may be asked a scenario where they are taking into consideration right the kind of the different questions there's a scenario where.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm Mr Mrs X comma, the project manager comma is contemplating the following questions like the ones you see on your screen what is.
**Susan Daniels**: You know the project manager doing, and you need to identify that what this task is is they're trying to determine whether to make or by they can ask in a variety of ways.
**Susan Daniels**: There was also a question about who decides for maker by you know whose decision is it.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, this is all part of your procurement management plan right you've identified the different requirements you found the gaps.
**Susan Daniels**: you're making our proposal right you get the right people in the room to like the stakeholders, the ones that gonna actually have to use this in thing.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm or the end result you get the stakeholders that are most vested plus your sponsors to kind of make a decision on whether this should be pursued or not.
**Susan Daniels**: But before you even hold those meetings you put your procurement management plan together and you send it up going, these are the following items that are potentially make.
**Susan Daniels**: Potentially for vendors are for procurement right and i'm going to hold maker by meetings right on these elements, and these are who i'm going to invite.
**Susan Daniels**: So you send that up before you have first meeting before you do any of the work you send it up to your sponsors and go hey, this is what i'm thinking and doing, do you agree.
**Susan Daniels**: And they will let you know rather rapidly Oh, we definitely need to go out of house for this this one that goes invite me to this maker by Decision right, I want to be a part of that or they agree with your approach, but this is where the conversation and direction get started.
**Susan Daniels**: plan your work, get approval and then go do your plan.
**Susan Daniels**: um.
**Susan Daniels**: I hope that's helpful.
**Susan Daniels**: What is the name of the video if you're going to rewatch it on maker by let's call it maker by analysis.
**Susan Daniels**: Another key element, and this is before we've really even started to do we're still kind of creating our plan this point right we're still.
**Susan Daniels**: Looking at what we're going to do and what we need to do so, another element of that is something called a statement of work and before I keep talking i'm going to go ahead and let you read the slide for a couple of moments, and then i'll try to build out upon it.
Thanks.
**Susan Daniels**: For your notes.
**Susan Daniels**: When you're taking the test the test questions are written from the perspective that the project manager is the buyer, I repeat, during the test the perspective, the questions are written from our from you are the buyer okay.
**Susan Daniels**: You have a project and you're trying to get the resources to do that project okay.
**Susan Daniels**: I know a lot of you work with organizations that go out and get bids, based upon the statement of work, and then you guys try to execute based upon the contract that your company got.
**Susan Daniels**: But that is not the perspective, the test is is written from it is written from your organization.
**Susan Daniels**: has authorized a project and to get it done, you have to potentially go at a house and you have to go out a house and do that you're starting document to go out a house is your statement of work.
**Susan Daniels**: This presumes you've already been through the make or by analysis and you've landed on or gonna have to buy it.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so, then you start to write out what it is that you need from the arm the provider the vendor okay this statement of work, then becomes what the contractor uses to build out their execution plan okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so these considerations are part of what you put into your procurement management plan yeah analyze all the requirements find your gaps.
**Susan Daniels**: Tell your leadership in your plan I got these gaps right, I want to hold these maker by analysis meetings and we may potentially be writing statements of work right for these following our areas okay.
**Susan Daniels**: In your plan you're also going to be very clear that you're going to use the standardized procurement documents Okay, this is your way of telling leadership.
**Susan Daniels**: I know there's pre existing legal documents this organization uses okay i've already done my homework i've made my contacts internally i've talked to procurement and i'm going to use their standardized processes and documents.
**Susan Daniels**: Is sort of reassures them that you're not out there winging it on the phone and trying to contract, the company through email I hate hey now you're not going to go that way, I mean that you are going to use standardized processes.
**Susan Daniels**: Because, believe me, there are project managers out there who are just free wheeling and you know called some.
**Susan Daniels**: Just independently out there, making stuff happen without playing by the rules of the game, so you want to assure your sponsors that.
**Susan Daniels**: i've looked into this again and i'm going to follow the standard way of doing it.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, one of the things that you want to talk about since you've already said i'm going to go and i'm you know we're going to look at these maker by analysis if so i'm going to have to create statements of work and then i'm going to hold bidding conferences now.
**Susan Daniels**: The next couple of slides are all about how do you go about.
**Susan Daniels**: That building out figuring out your vendors and how do you set up your contracts, you know there's there's a lot of slides we're about to cover.
**Susan Daniels**: But you need to affirm to your leadership that you are going to be compliant and bidding on an evaluation of bids in a ethical and standardized way.
**Susan Daniels**: Now if you've never been in a.
**Susan Daniels**: bitters conference that is something you should probably ask peers to mentor you about okay.
**Susan Daniels**: we've got a slide on that, but it depends on how time unfolds on how deep I can go about conducting bidding conferences, but this procurement management plan is really just giving a thumbs up and affirming to them.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm not going to freewheel i'm not going to just independently on my own accord go out and make this happen, the way, I think it should be, there are very much processes in place around this.
**Susan Daniels**: um so i've got john asking um it doesn't make sense to have quotes in biz before we make any final maker by Decision um.
**Susan Daniels**: It really depends on how you want to approach it your maker by.
**Susan Daniels**: oftentimes is just whether we're even going to try to go at a house or not right and we can still always withdraw but.
**Susan Daniels**: where you are in process here is, should this be a maker by right then we'll figure out who we want to buy it from when we get our bids and our own quotes from night so maker by is before you engage your vendors.
**Susan Daniels**: So now we're at the point that we've got the green light to go out and procure outside a house.
**Susan Daniels**: source selection criteria.
**Susan Daniels**: This is something that is written before you publish any statement of work that you want done.
**Susan Daniels**: You before you let the world know that you're looking for people just you know, to help you you sit down with the procurement office or your sponsors and you write a source selection criteria.
**Susan Daniels**: What do these people have to be able to demonstrate relative to some of the items on the checklist here be for you to even qualify them to be.
**Susan Daniels**: A vendor for you right.
**Susan Daniels**: Some companies do that the pyramid department does this for you, they already have a pre existing list of qualified vendors, who.
**Susan Daniels**: That is a good good thing what that does is it accelerates your project, and thank you go to procurement and you say i'm looking to purchase the following and the goal here's the dream companies we've pre qualified.
**Susan Daniels**: Hot damn you are so much further down the road, if you have saved a couple of weeks right, so you that's a good thing if that doesn't exist.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, now you've got to have your vendors, you know answer a questionnaire and provide references, you have to do research on Dun and bradstreet you've got a lot of work, just to figure out who qualifies to do business with you.
**Susan Daniels**: So the second thing that the source selection criteria does for you is that, if it exists in advance if you have it already built, then, if you should have some.
**Susan Daniels**: Senior Vice President just happened by your desk one day and tell you how for this company as and how much they really recommend them to you to us okay.
**Susan Daniels**: And they they're literally trying to influence your decision, and suddenly may go so far as to insinuate that there may be consequences if you don't pick this vendor okay.
**Susan Daniels**: I live this more than once, it is a very good thing to be able to say, well, thank you for bringing that company to my attention.
**Susan Daniels**: we've already set the source selection criteria for our vendors, hopefully they'll come out on top of through the selection criteria and we'll be able to work with them.
**Susan Daniels**: and other words they gotta compete against others to this source that you've got a filter up okay.
**Susan Daniels**: they've got to make it through the filter it's not enough that they just said.
**Susan Daniels**: I said so right or they want to say, because I said they can't tell you, you have to use that vendor oftentimes but they want you to leave to believe that you should.
**Susan Daniels**: Right and you need to be able to be a political neutral right and simply say, well, thank you for bringing them to my attention.
**Susan Daniels**: i'll be looking for them when we're going through this or selection criteria with all of our you know our vendors is summit Okay, hopefully they'll come out, you know, on dub.
**Susan Daniels**: Like it's not your decision right you've got this safe gardens not really your place so they just wasting their time okay so it's it's a good thing.
**Susan Daniels**: Qualified vendors fast forward now we have actually got a set of vendors through our selection criteria or we got the shortlist from procurement okay.
**Susan Daniels**: that's what you're qualified vendors are it's the ones that have made it through the selection criteria they've been and here's an interesting word, they have been vetted okay um they have been approved okay usually by a small team often extremely often you have requirement team.
**Susan Daniels**: OK OK, so now that we have our set of qualified vendors, now we have to play fair with all Okay, and the way that we play fair with all is through a bitters conference i'm going to pause and let you look at the information on this slide and then we'll talk more about it.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: The purpose of a bit of bitters conference is to provide all vendors answers to their questions Okay, but they need to get the same information.
**Susan Daniels**: In the same way, at the same time, let me, let me restate that this is really important, you guys bitters conferences are to answer bitters questions.
**Susan Daniels**: about the statement of work and expectations right maybe about the site, the company, the context of which they're going to be working answer this same to answer their questions in the same give them the same answer in the same way, at the same time.
**Susan Daniels**: What I mean by in the same way, knowing it's to ask a question one off and get a one off answer Okay, and then everybody else get copied on it later no they get the same information same time in the same way, otherwise the bid can be overturned Okay, it can be challenged and overturned.
**Susan Daniels**: Challenging a vendors can challenge the bidding process if they think that somebody has an unfair advantage.
**Susan Daniels**: Which means somebody's got information before they did or got information that nobody else has okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So.
**Susan Daniels**: As a project manager sitting in a bitters conference your role nine times out of 10 assuming that procurement.
**Susan Daniels**: Who are pros at this are going to facilitate the conference mean they've been trained they got certifications for it.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay you're just there to answer questions about the statement of work okay about the product itself that you want produced.
**Susan Daniels**: you're reading the requirements you're reading the specifications Okay, you are, and if you don't know the answer to the question you.
**Susan Daniels**: collect the question from the bitters conference go back and work it with the relevant accountable parties and then you're able to send it back to procurement for distribution to the arm the vendors.
**Susan Daniels**: At no time should you ever answer a question from anyone in the hallway or anyone in the elevator or anyone in the parking lot who goes, excuse me, you know i've got my hearing aid was acting up while I was in the conference, and I just wanted to ask you a question.
**Susan Daniels**: You need to back away from that person Okay, and say I cannot answer that question.
**Susan Daniels**: And you need to say it loudly, not because he has a hearing aid because there are spotters sitting around watching you, and if they see you talk to someone in that bitters conference and answer a question, they can challenge that bid based upon unfair advantage.
**Susan Daniels**: Do you want to be that guy that gets the whole procurement process starting over again.
**Susan Daniels**: Think that's going to have an impact on your schedule.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, it might have an impact on your career so at bitters conferences.
**Susan Daniels**: Keep your mouth shut talk to no one unless authorized by the bitters conference facilitator answer the question shut up okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Talk to know and going into the bitters conference talk to no one coming out of the bidders conference until you are back in a space where you recognize everyone around you.
**Susan Daniels**: There are no strangers around you then you're free to talk I just my life experience advice about bitters conference proceed with caution they're very legalistic environments and they have very serious consequences, especially if there's a lot of money on the table.
**Susan Daniels**: Who would govern a bitter stating unfairness, they just simply need to challenge it Okay, they submit the grounds or justification for their challenge it gets investigated.
**Susan Daniels**: It really depends on what business domain you're in and who you're engaging right there are all kinds of oversight regulatory bodies.
**Susan Daniels**: And even your procurement team can call foul right and say yep That was a mistake and we need to start over so it can be really anyone from internal to your company to you know the oversight of government regulatory bodies.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: um.
**Susan Daniels**: Is a bit as conference like a request for proposal aren't rfp no no they're not a request for proposal is when you're sending out those statements of work and you're saying can anybody give me.
**Susan Daniels**: feedback on this and who would like to work on it that's just kind of a request for proposal is how you begin to collect.
**Susan Daniels**: vendors that are interested you run them through your selection criteria qualify them and then you start your your actual bidding and your bidding process Okay, I need to move on guys.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: This is a slide to just basically says, sometimes you need to go out of house, I think this one may be slightly out of order okay.
**Susan Daniels**: To do that, you look at suppliers and contractors, and this is where we're going to start to talk about different kinds of contracts and how you talk to them.
**Susan Daniels**: yeah we're getting into contract types.
**Susan Daniels**: You need to know each one of these on this slide you need to know the difference between each one of these okay.
**Susan Daniels**: We have slides to build out on these, but when you see fixed price time and materials on target cost contracts you're all you're very much into procurement and you're very much into understanding different ways of compensation hey let's see.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Good there is a slide I can go deep on each one forgive me.
**Susan Daniels**: One of the things that you build into your contract okay is you're managing expectations for.
**Susan Daniels**: How frequently they need to provide you updates, let me put it, a different way when you're running a project.
**Susan Daniels**: And you have accountable parties inside your organization and they owe you periodic performance updates right inside the organization, you have the authority as the project manager, to tell the accountable person.
**Susan Daniels**: At this cadence you need to provide me status updates well, you have the same authority over your vendor relationships, so they can you can write into the contract that they are going to give you performance updates and you develop your own performance.
**Susan Daniels**: Requirements performance reporting requirements, sometimes you develop your own template for performance reporting requirements.
**Susan Daniels**: Sometimes, if they've got a pre existing template in place because of your industry or because of your Organization has worked with this vendor for years you just give him another bed kind of like jumping on a running train.
**Susan Daniels**: Then you don't have to do a lot of work in this space, but if it's a smaller organization if falls in your court it's your responsibility to design the performance reporting expectations and templates sometimes for your vendors.
**Susan Daniels**: Why, there is almost light on this is that sometimes procurement will forget this, because they don't care that much they're more about i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: sticking to the rules of how to do procurement and writing the contract and getting all the legal documents done and they figure it's up to you.
**Susan Daniels**: You know, to negotiate your communications is in there right, so this whole slide is to say hey don't forget to put your part in to make sure that in the contract itself, they are going to be compliant with your your.
**Susan Daniels**: Your performance reporting.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: There are several components of a contract.
**Susan Daniels**: i'll give you a moment to consume to consume that.
**Susan Daniels**: This is just helpful if you're trying to um draft Okay, a contract, you are working for a startup right you begin the project manager for a startup and you don't have a procurement department and you're trying to really.
**Susan Daniels**: start from a bottoms up very, very small company, maybe even your own company um it's important to know that there are certain elements in a contract that are required.
**Susan Daniels**: For it to be binding OK.
**Susan Daniels**: The next thing I want to talk about are the different types of contracts, you will be given descriptions of contracting situations and they will ask you which one is most applicable like which would be the most applicable type of contract to use here is almost always a scenario.
**Susan Daniels**: Paragraph thing, so one of the things that I would flag, you know every once while I tell you put a star on this one, this is a very important slide, this is one of them.
**Susan Daniels**: You need to be able to totally recall this slide and understand the difference between fixed price cost reimbursement in time and material.
**Susan Daniels**: So.
**Susan Daniels**: It does i'm not going to go into great lecture here because there's a really good video on it, and you know the videos are like outstanding so i'm not going to.
**Susan Daniels**: You know, try to expand much upon it, but I will have you put a couple of notes just a couple of written notes fixed price scope is well defined.
**Susan Daniels**: scope is well defined or it already is built okay fixed price you're buying something from the supplier where is he's already built it and you're just buying it for the prices set.
**Susan Daniels**: Or you know exactly what you want to the specifications and he can cost it out completely and be ready to offer you a very fixed price that's a win for him and an acceptable to you okay cost reimbursement scope is not well defined.
**Susan Daniels**: So you're going to pay them as they go to develop it so that you can you can define success okay.
**Susan Daniels**: But you don't know how long it's going to take to get there are all the efforts is going to take to get it done but you know what successes I you can set the.
**Susan Daniels**: The criteria of what you need, but sometimes the scope is not well defined on because the situation that they're working in maybe evolving.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, and they have to get into it, to be able to unpack this situation before they can really you know tell you what the cost is so you agreed to do pass along of standard cost until the work is done.
**Susan Daniels**: Time and material okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Please putting in as used in an emergency Okay, which means when there is not time to negotiate okay you don't have time to negotiate on.
**Susan Daniels**: What kind of in depth robust contracting arrangement right for cost reimbursement and you can't really necessarily set a fixed price with them, so you go time and materials.
**Susan Daniels**: Please put in your nose least favorable time and materials least favorable for the buyer.
**Susan Daniels**: To the extent possible when you're contracting as the project manager on the exam you're the buyer.
**Susan Daniels**: Time and materials is least favorable option only done in a.
**Susan Daniels**: emergency situation is usually, when it's.
**Susan Daniels**: applicable.
**Susan Daniels**: So let's see.
**Susan Daniels**: The next slide though before we get into the video answers a question from much earlier on, which was does, how do you pay you budget for agile projects, how do you, you know manage costs an agile.
**Susan Daniels**: environment if you've got an agile environment with someone building your website, you know well, this slide is great I included to back then that there were some innovative contracting methods going on now beyond just kind of.
**Susan Daniels**: Time and materials and i'm gonna i'm not going to build out on these extensively, but you should study this slide if only to recognize by description.
**Susan Daniels**: That this is an agile type of contracting and maybe by description, what type is matching this to this but definitely matching these kinds of contracts to agile.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay i've got a question from Roy what is a contract vehicle um basically is the the actual type of contract that you're going to use.
**Susan Daniels**: That type of contract the contract vehicle which one, are you going to ride, is it going to be fixed price cost reimbursement cost reimbursement with incentives fixed price with.
**Susan Daniels**: With incentives how what kinda you doing okay so we're now at the point we're going to watch this okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay silly to say only a couple minutes.
**Susan Daniels**: Once you decide that it makes sense to go with a vendor the next decision to be made is the type of contract that should be used.
**Susan Daniels**: In this course will introduce three common contract types, first we have fixed price contracts fixed price contracts are useful when there is a defined scope.
**Susan Daniels**: We can introduce variations of this contract type to incorporate financial incentives as well.
**Susan Daniels**: With fixed price contract the seller is obligated to complete the work and the buyer is protected, because all of the specifics are detailed and agreed upon in advance.
**Susan Daniels**: Next, there are cost reimbursement contracts these allow for a flexible scope, like the fixed price contracts, we can introduce variations to incorporate financial incentives.
**Susan Daniels**: This contract type is a bit riskier for the buyer because the specifics of the scope are not so well defined and changes to the scope, can potentially impact the cost.
**Susan Daniels**: And finally, we have time and materials contracts, this type of contract contains aspects of both fixed and cost reimbursement contract types the unit Labor or material rates are used and to protect the buyer and not to exceed value may also be included.
There are variations of the fixed price and cost reimburse of all contracts and which variation you use depends on the situation.
For instance, you may want to incentivize your vendor if your project has a tight timeline or cost constraints incentive fees can make it worthwhile for the vendor to help you achieve your goals.
awards are another possibility and can be built into your contracts also you may need to consider building in economic price adjustments in case the cost of a raw material increases or decreases in the middle of your project work.
**Susan Daniels**: So I got a good question in the chat and I do want to thank you all for following the ground rules of keeping the chat you know, relative to just the topic at hand.
**Susan Daniels**: really helping to be much more dynamic and interactive so I wanted to answer these questions Susan for the agile contract types, which is the most favorable for a buyer standpoint.
**Susan Daniels**: um, to the extent possible customers review contracts during the contract lifecycle at a pre negotiated designated point of the contract lifecycle.
**Susan Daniels**: What this allows you to do is you're literally kind of buying one increment at a time okay and you're saying, for it let's use a website, you want to do a website.
**Susan Daniels**: So you over the next month agree that in the next month they're going to do the framework and they're going to do the graphics and they're going to do the arms some of the graphics so with the understanding what's happening in the different frames.
**Susan Daniels**: They at the end of the month, and they come back to you, and they show you you've contracted a certain amount for that month's work, I mean you've built it into.
**Susan Daniels**: Your plan you've got a backlog list of all the things you want done broken down right.
**Susan Daniels**: And you only paying one point, at a time what that allows you to do you know what it costs for a month's worth of work right you've got what you've agreed to be done in the month.
**Susan Daniels**: But it allows you to stop at any point with them okay so it's a contract is written that basically says this might be a year long contract to be reviewed on a X.
**Susan Daniels**: interval right work will be submitted reviewed for approval on X interval i'm termination can occur, based upon quality of work, submitted.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, and that keeps that person on their toes and you know every month your bill won't be any more than X right because you've kind of agreed to your monthly charge.
**Susan Daniels**: So it's to me that's the most favorable as a buyer anything that's cost reimbursement who that's kind of an open ended check.
**Susan Daniels**: And that's sort of like it just keeps kind of going you want to put do not to exceed if you can write well i'm going to contract cost reimbursement, not to exceed.
**Susan Daniels**: That anytime you put in, not to exceed yes that's a stop guard and a protection for you, but that kind of tells the seller, I can get up to that much money and dang that's how much money, I think this is going to cost.
**Susan Daniels**: Right, so not really as optimal as just contracting and an increment the good question go in there um.
**Susan Daniels**: um we are always the buyer organization okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So we're getting close to coming up on it on another break but i've got a couple of slides I need to get through, so a break might be just a couple minutes after the quarter hour, but we're ending up close to one just wanted to let you know okay so.
**Susan Daniels**: One thing that you need to be a one of your roles okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Is that.
**Susan Daniels**: um you need to know your the communication map conduit between the vendor and on the party that is benefiting okay from their work.
**Susan Daniels**: They the the vendor talks to you right they have the performance report that comes to you, they bring the part they bring the problems to you.
**Susan Daniels**: The people who are getting the benefit of the work, bring the problems to you Okay, you are that negotiator remember how we started, one of the first things we talked about on day one in the beginning was the importance of negotiation Okay, so we are put in the middle here to negotiate.
**Susan Daniels**: it's very important that you know when the work has been completed.
**Susan Daniels**: They need to tell you they think they're finished you've got to get approval from the in party receiving the benefit of this work they've got to concur that the work has been approved sign off on it and you got to make sure the final payment is made through accounts payable.
**Susan Daniels**: Unfortunately, in many projects that step gets overlooked.
**Susan Daniels**: It doesn't formal closing doesn't happen, where they make sure that that last amount of payment that that final checklist has been done, often called a Punch list has been done and that last payment has been released oh you'll get the final.
**Susan Daniels**: invoice in and you'll hear from.
**Susan Daniels**: The party in the hall, you can go hey are you satisfied with xyz companies work i'm i've got their final in this oh yeah i'm good i'm good.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, great, but the ball gets dropped to tell accounts payable release all funds, you know get we pay this plus any held back funds and release it to the vendor otherwise.
**Susan Daniels**: accounts payable may be sitting with the paint the invoice as well as some hold back money but hold back money is kind of using management reserves.
**Susan Daniels**: With your vendor will pay you, but the first need will pay you X amount and we're going to hold back X, from the beginning, will pay you 100,000 we're going to hold back 20%.
**Susan Daniels**: Until we're completely satisfied, so they know that this is common contracting and they send their final invoice but.
**Susan Daniels**: accounts payable still waiting for you okay now just to send the last invoice but to a firm to release the last money okay just just a part of contracting, you should be sensitive to.
**Susan Daniels**: So just like you had to write a formal change control process for your internal right.
**Susan Daniels**: changes that are happening with your internal organization, you need to have a method in a process in place with your vendors okay um how do they get changes approved Okay, how do you get changes notification of changes, and they need for changes, you need to develop that process.
**Susan Daniels**: Usually is brought to you in writing in a formal way so let's talk about the different kinds of changes that they're there can be in contracts, some are much more significant than others okay so let's start at the light into the scale administrative changes.
**Susan Daniels**: This is simply when the key contact person for submitting information to us to be susie but Susan found another job she looked to went to Paris is not coming back so now you've got somebody new is one so now, you need to notify your vendor Please submit documents to one.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay that's just an administrative change, maybe on a web feel the email address that they they submit information to changes, these are just simple non substantive changes, but they still have to be communicated.
**Susan Daniels**: Contract modifications.
**Susan Daniels**: On these are significant, this is when you're like changing the deadline okay are adding on new requirements right, this is.
**Susan Daniels**: A substantive mean this is really like a formal change we thought we wanted something right, but now that we've gotten to it, we want to change our expectations.
**Susan Daniels**: These are negotiated right, and they are well documented you update the statement of work, you update the contract compensation amount.
**Susan Daniels**: You may change the due dates you Okay, you may have to augment or change the performance report that to now address this as well Okay, these are contract modifications.
**Susan Daniels**: supplemental agreements, these are really common you may find this frequently in your career.
**Susan Daniels**: Member how I mentioned that procurement will have a short list of pre qualified vendors they've been vetted this is who we do business with for that kind of work.
**Susan Daniels**: Yes, it's a good thing Okay, you want to have that, but the question is when there's a standard contract.
**Susan Daniels**: And this company, then what you wanted to do just becomes like an addendum or a supplement to an already existing contract in place an example of that would be let's say your company contracts for.
**Susan Daniels**: talent, with a particular temp agency right, and you have been told of the three temp agencies your company works with.
**Susan Daniels**: This is the one that can meet your need so your your contract for these tips staff that you want is just a supplement with already existing.
**Susan Daniels**: This company is providing temp staff here and there and everywhere in your enterprise they've got people embedded everywhere in your organization you're just one more place.
**Susan Daniels**: Not is kind of supplemental agreement okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Those are easy to work with they're very quickly executed, I like them, the only downside is, and unfortunately it does happen with very negative consequences, sometimes these.
**Susan Daniels**: Pre vetted pre qualified contractors get on the wrong side of senior leadership somebody just does something wrong and senior leadership says we're not doing business with any of you anymore.
**Susan Daniels**: Excuse me.
**Susan Daniels**: Consequently, all of those supplemental contracts are now not all invoice.
**Susan Daniels**: and your project was running you hand your staff and now those people are missing.
**Susan Daniels**: And they're not coming back so they're good things are faster efficient, but they can you can have a legs pulled out from under you in a heartbeat hang on a minute guys.
**Susan Daniels**: constructive changes, these are changes that.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm by action or inaction, you now have made more work.
**Susan Daniels**: On this is when something kind of goes wrong on the job site and now it's going to take more work to get it done.
**Susan Daniels**: And if that's a change right and now they've got to add the work and the effort to compensate for that setback, and the more time and the more money to recover what happened, and now you get back on track, so constructive changes or when you're trying to basically get.
**Susan Daniels**: From my experience get your project back on track in with your vendor and, of course, the biggest changes, when you terminate a contract.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: bear with me, I really only have on one more slide that I need to do.
**Susan Daniels**: And then we'll go on break.
**Susan Daniels**: give you a moment to look at this.
**Susan Daniels**: These are different kinds of conflicts that can happen with your with your your relationship with your vendor.
**Susan Daniels**: Most of the changes that we have up here Okay, this is, you know just everybody's on positive terms everything's working well we're just you know collaborating.
**Susan Daniels**: Until we terminate.
**Susan Daniels**: A warranty usually comes in, when something's not meeting quality expectations right, and now they got to come back in and they've got to fix it, you are going to exercise the warranty on this body of work okay.
**Susan Daniels**: You don't want to get to the point where you have to use the warranty Okay, but when you're writing your contract, you want to make sure that there's always a warranty component in your contractual relationship, you know, in your formal contract.
**Susan Daniels**: Because, sometimes on you may need to go with procurement or with legal and say I need to exercise the warranty.
**Susan Daniels**: waiver oh Okay, this is important.
**Susan Daniels**: So you've set forth expectations and the statement of work you've set forth performance expectations you've set forth even communication expectations right in this contract.
**Susan Daniels**: And i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Take the example you're expecting a performance update by the first of each month, that is the expectation.
**Susan Daniels**: And you get a phone call on the first is on a Monday, so you get a phone call on Sunday, so that when you come in and you're like picking up your.
**Susan Daniels**: Your voicemails I know that's archaic, but I still use voicemails you pick up your communications preferred channel and we'll use.
**Susan Daniels**: Charlie the contractor Charlie leaves you this message saying hey Susan I know I owe you a performance report, but you know my family's got coven i'm i've been my hands have been full i'll have it to you on Tuesday Okay, I know I owe it i'll get it to you.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm sorry for the delay Now you can probably live waiting until Tuesday to get your your performance report, I mean you don't know anything upstairs until Wednesday anyway.
**Susan Daniels**: So you think it's okay you and Charlie have a good working relationship.
**Susan Daniels**: But you need to respond to Charlie by saying, Charlie, thank you for the update regarding the status of the performance report.
**Susan Daniels**: Please know that i'm not waving my rights to have this performance report do every first of the month okay period.
**Susan Daniels**: Please get this to me as soon as possible, no later than close a business Tuesday, you want to explicitly restate that this requirement that was not met is not being waved okay why, why would I go through that kind of technical effort.
**Susan Daniels**: Because if you accept charlie's lateness once of not meeting a requirement once it can be presumed that you're waving that going forward and Charlie can start delivering things on the second or the third or the fourth the fifth until you start complaining and hold them to it right.
**Susan Daniels**: My advice to you is to be firm and fair in your contract, so you formally document you're not waving this and you, you know you want it by X date but you expected in the future to be on the first.
**Susan Daniels**: But you can leave a warm voicemail back to Charlie i'm sorry that your you know your family has coven very challenging.
**Susan Daniels**: I appreciate the early notice and allow me to adapt thanks Charlie right, you can have a personal relationship, but you have to keep your legal relationship well documented, or else you're waving rights.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm giving you a simple example of a performance under achievement imagine what it would mean if you waive something that's a quality measure okay.
**Susan Daniels**: A breach of contract happens when one party or the other causes damages okay or financial loss.
**Susan Daniels**: A breach of contract is material when there are damages.
**Susan Daniels**: This is when you can start to pursue recourse, this is when you start going for compensation or you may end up in mediation arbitration okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So you have breaches of contract some of material, some are not material Okay, I am.
**Susan Daniels**: A material breach contract is again when there are damages and there is compensation that need can be pursued.
**Susan Daniels**: cease and desist letter, these are important this is kind of your PR pre warning to them that this, you are so far below expectations that we want you to stop and we're going to pursue basically termination of this contract that is a serious dispute okay.
**Susan Daniels**: But you should be familiar with these terms.
**Susan Daniels**: you've got two guidelines right, I want you to review at your convenience.
**Susan Daniels**: And when we come back from break we're going to jump back into a new topic, and when we talking about project governance structure.
**Susan Daniels**: However, during the break i'm gonna look at the chat and see if I can answer a couple of questions relative to procurement so let's get started i'm in the interest of staying and cadence i'm going to ask you guys to just take a 10 minute break at this time i'll see you back in a few.